why is it do you think that it's not
more prevalent in our society and media
and just people in general to talk about
how diet can be related to these cancers
it's kind of hushed it's just not
mentioned at all it's hard enough to get
a little cynical and I don't want to
fall off into conspiracy land here but
we can be honest there's a lot of
interest making a lot of money so you
can keep Americans eating like they are
and to keep those Burgers going down
people's throats and to sell them all
the fatty meats and salamis and fast
foods money money money is driving so
much of this and government subsidies
make these Foods artificially cheap so
if you're a single mom with four kids to
feed it's cheaper to go to McDonald's
than it is to style a cup of produce and
so there's many Market forces that are
conspiring against healthy eating if it
was just pure science it should be on
billboards it should be on TV
commercials twice an hour stop eating
the meat Nigerian oils and sugars in the
processed foods eat more fruits
vegetables make some stews and soups and
salads and eat whole plant Foods you
know there should be on the TV
commercials and everything would change
but a lot of people making a lot of
money from the status quo and it's just
not serving us and we're paying all
paying the consequences yeah
that was Dr Michael Clapper one of my
favorite plant-based Physicians and
medical Minds now on the podcast for a
second time an internationally
recognized teacher speaker and gifted
medical practitioner he's been helping
patients reverse chronic illness with
plant-based nutrition and integrative
medicine for the last 40 years helping
thousands of people reclaim their health
and needful Vitality Dr Clapper served
as director of the nonprofit Institute
of nutrition Education and Research and
was a member of the nutrition task force
of the American Medical Student
Association he now works full-time with
moving medicine forward where he
lectures at medical schools Across the
Nation educating students on plant-based
nutrition and lifestyle changes to
restore their patients health and truly
heal we know that healthy dietary
patterns are a key component to
preventing and even reversing many of
the most common diseases that are
prevalent here in the U.S yet nutrition
education is still rarely taught in
medical school curriculums so the pill
for every ill continues on that's why Dr
clapper's work with moving medicine
forward is so integral in changing the
game of our current Medical system in
this episode we hone in on optimal
nutrition for preventing America's
biggest Killers heart disease and many
types of diet related cancers we also
discussed how to build a nutritious
plate and what specific foods help
protect you against these cancers what
an incredible episode I hope you love it
as much as I do welcome to the elevation
podcast
so I just got a new safe sleeve for my
phone which is a 5G EMF radiation
protection case and I'm super stoked
about it safe sleeve offers
anti-radiation products designed to give
you the Peace of Mind of knowing you and
your devices are protected while making
them even easier to use all of their
anti-radiation products incorporate lab
tested shielding technology that can
block over 99 of RF and 92 percent of
Elf radiation there are very few
anti-radiation brands that offer lab
tested protection theirs is publicly
available on their website and maybe one
to two others that block elf elf is much
harder to block but equally as important
and all of their cell phone cases
provide military grade drop protection
which is also tested by a third party
evaluator not only that these cases come
in different colors to suit your
favorite style and there's even a place
for your bank cards and cash so
everything is in one easy to use place I
got the detachable case for my iPhone
which turns into a stand and includes
the ability to magnetically remove the
protective inner case for car mounting
and safe sleeve also has cases for your
tablet and laptop too and I got a
discount code for you guys so you too
can protect yourself from EMF radiation
with safe sleeve click my link below and
enter the code ln10 to get 10 off your
safely purchase all right thank you Dr
Clapper so much for being here again how
has your trip been oh it's been
wonderful the people that are wonderful
and Maui is always fabulous it's been
great to be here oh good I'm so glad
you're here and I thought we could start
the conversation where you could update
people a little bit on the moving
medicine forward initiative what you're
doing full time and why indeed thank you
uh well moving medicine forward is my
attempt our attempt to fill in this
grotesque vacuum this hole in modern
Medical education where doctors are
churned out with their medical degree
without ever considering the effect of
the patient's daily diet on the diseases
they're spending their careers and
treating and it's turning out that
indeed what our patients are reading is
the major cause why their arteries clog
why they become obese why they become
inflamed and the good news if you get
these folks on a truly healthy Whole
Food plant-based diet most these
diseases go away these reversible
diseases I wish someone had told me that
when I was in medical school you must
take blood pressure pills the rest of
your life is Lifetime medication no one
gets off insulin that's what I was told
but if the truth is the exact opposite
these are reversible diseases we get
people off their blood pressure pills
and Insulin all the time as they get
leaner and healthier than a plant-based
diet and I was thinking somebody ought
to tell to reach those first second
third year medical students with this
message before pharmacose sclerosis sets
into their brain and they think that
drug in surgery the only treatment that
they can someone ought to tell these
students that the little boy says how
about you Doc and that was three years
ago and since then I we've achieved our
501c3 nonprofit status and I've been
going around to the nation's medical
schools giving the students the lecture
I wish someone had given me 50 years ago
and telling them it's what your patients
are running through their bloodstream
every four hours with their food is why
they're sitting in front of you Doctor
overweight hypertensive diabetic clogged
up and inflamed send these people to the
plant-based dietitian let her get them
on a plant-based diet and I walk every
day you see them back in a month and see
if they're not healthier and see if you
can start reducing some of their
medications that's how medicine should
be practiced in the 21st century if
someone had told me that it would have
changed the course of my whole medical
career so we were trying to get that
message into the minds and hearts of
again the first second third fourth year
medical students but we let you to the
residents and the fellows and if I was
just both the gastroenterology fellows
of the University of Texas last month
very receptive they're all very
receptive they know something's up with
nutrition but they haven't had an
experienced physician stand in front of
them saying it's what your patients are
eating doctors start there before you
order another thousand dollar scan
another 500 lamb to ask them what they
ate yesterday and if it's full of
burgers and buffalo wings that's the
problem let's help these patients get on
truly healthy diet and moving medicine
forwards gives the uh the guidance and
the resources to help people achieve
really healthy diet work with a food
coach whatever they need so I'm trying
to film that that crucial Missing Link
because my Noble profession has been a
major bottleneck in preventing this huge
transition to plant-based diets that we
all need to make that the doctors were
really behind this and doing it
themselves and at every visit hi Joe
how's your plant-based diet going I I've
lost 20 pounds how are you doing with it
if everybody heard a really positive
message from their doctor it would
change everything so I'm trying to work
at that acupuncture Point uh we can get
the medical profession on board and that
would certainly open the gates to some
major changes here so that's what moving
medicine forward is directed to and we
are slowly but surely succeeding and if
anyone would like to uh learn about our
work or how to support us I'm sure
you'll have the contact information down
we accept all sorts of donations from
all sorts of modalities Ellen venmo and
all that and so it would be great if you
get that word out but trying to make
things better when it comes to why does
my doctor know anything about nutrition
we're trying to answer that question in
the best possible way amazing and I'm so
glad to hear that people are being
receptive to it and do you think do you
think that we will be able to get
nutrition into the medical schooling at
some point why and why is it that it's
not in there yet oh absolutely and again
it's been part of this huge blind spot
uh that medical education uh has uh has
incorporated that they don't want to
talk about food because it gets into
sensitive areas I mean I can't eat five
cheeseburgers a week and you're gonna
tell me I can't have buffalo wings and
hot dogs every day uh that's the nanny
State tell them no one's going to tell
me that I can eat or drink but your
arteries don't care about how you feel
uh you're an intestinal floor doesn't
care about how you feel they just want a
whole food plant-based diet coming down
to function optimally and so
um so it's generally been ignored both
in the crew in the curriculum planning
in Med schools as well as the the
testing and uh the University of
Washington Seattle a couple years years
ago I gave a talk and a surgeon came
approached me later said in a doctor
very nice lecture very important but
until they started asking these
questions on the national board exams no
we're not going to be teaching this
stuff it's enough to get all the rest of
the stuff into the curriculum and I
realized there was a ring of Truth to
that so what do you do well we went to
the national board of medical examiners
and said what will it take to for you
guys start putting
questions about nutrition Applied
Nutrition on the diet on the on the exam
he says well we don't know anything
about the subject well that's no excuse
yeah it's important they said well if
you make up the questions we'll we'll
put them on so um so the American
College of Lifestyle medicine got a
panel together and put together a
thousand questions on plant-based
nutrition and submitted them to the
board and hopefully we will start seeing
them
showing up on the national board exams
which will be a major step
uh but also the the medical residents
the students they're asking for it uh
for the for this information to be
available in every med school class now
there's 20 or 30 students they've seen
films like Forks Over Knives they've
seen what the hell they've seen
conspiracy the lights on they know
something's up with nutrition they need
an experienced clinician to tell them
this is not California woo-woo stuff
this is the Bedrock physiology of the
disease you're going to be treating and
uh and once that message gets out the
very very little resistance uh every
once in a while they'll be a professor
in the back of the room with his arms
folded and giving on uh
unwelcome uh reception to some of what
I'm saying because it threatens the
model it threatens the intellectual
model that food food doesn't make any
difference well it threatens that model
but of course friends are economic model
as far as if everybody adopts this
they'll be less
chest open in the stands placed and a
lot of the Band-Aid medicine and plus it
also threatens the cultural issues that
I grew up eating this food you know my
mother always made pancakes and sausage
every Sunday morning you know and uh you
know they're not going to take that away
from me so there's obstacles but again
the truth is the truth gorillas out in
the wild they're eating leaves and
fruits all day a high carbohydrate diet
they don't develop type 2 diabetes
because they're eating their native
natural diet of of high fiber whole
plant Foods well we have basically the
same digestive system that are bonobo
and gorilla cousins have and we thrive
on a diet of whole plant Foods and we
have the enzymes in our digestive system
to take apart starches and plant
proteins and then some late fats Etc but
when you start throwing down meat and
dairy and oils and sugars and all the
processed food chemicals whoa that's you
know it's like putting diesel fuel in a
gasoline burning engine and the spark
plugs following the gas line clogs up
and the mobile disease Unknown Origin
I've got a t-shirt says it's the food
it's been the food all along you know
and that's really that's really the
issue and uh and the especially the
younger students once they hear this the
the there's they're not really arguing
with it it becomes of course you know
why didn't I see this before so I'm just
helping them make that very important
intellectual step it's at least open to
the possibility that food makes a
difference because truth is it makes all
the difference yeah and that makes so
much sense because I think a lot of
Physicians and even medical students are
seeing that the prescription drug model
of just a pill for every ill is not
actually solving the problem and
Physicians go into you know to the
medical field to help people and so
getting that connection to see oh
nutrition such an important role in
helping with the prevention and even
reversal of chronic diseases absolutely
in fact on my website Dr clapper.com
people can click on the lecture what I
wish I learned in medical school about
nutrition they can see what I'm telling
the medical students there and um uh we
make it very clear that the um you know
when you eat a cheeseburger the the I
show them what happens in our
bloodstream and uh all the different
changes happen from the salt and the
sugar and the oils Etc and it suddenly
starts making a whole lot of sense to
them and uh very little resistance when
you're still in the science yes that's
awesome so for those who are listening
and are really interested in eating
plant-based or maybe they've even tried
eating that way before and they struggle
to be successful at it and to feel their
best and to make it long term what
advice do you have for someone wanting
to go towards a more Whole Foods
plant-based diet because last time we
had our conversation we did dabble in it
but let's get into it a little bit more
specifically for people who would like
some more details to make it successful
sure very important question and we want
people to always feel accomplished just
food and it's a matter of staying in
your comfort zone and so let's let's
take a breakfast a luncheon and dinner
and we can serve just one day a week you
know one meal a week uh one breakfast a
week let's see if we can make it totally
plant-based well it's a little easy and
breakfast just have some oatmeal with uh
your favorite fruits in there a little
bit of chopped nuts and some flax seeds
and uh some plant milk oatmeal hemp milk
one of those so that certainly works for
breakfast
um and so lunches and dinners what are
you going to have well for lunches or
classic soup and a sandwich and uh some
and maybe a little salad there that
would certainly work well there's lots
of wonderful hearty vegetable soups that
you can make and put some veggies and
pastas and Grains and beans and lentils
in there and seasoned however you'd like
and you can have that both for lunch and
dinner but there's our lunch soup uh and
a sandwich doesn't have to be ham and
cheese it can be a hummus sandwich
tomato and lettuce uh it can be enough
Butters and sandwich
lots of things to put on grilled
vegetables last thing to put on a
sandwich besides uh
needs and and if you do want to do a
rare treat or uh once a week treat
during transition of one of these now
and we'll have veggie burgers which are
fine once a week have one of those
whatever it takes to get you through
lunch and say huh that was a really
satisfying lunch and look no meat or
dairy involved yay now we're two-thirds
of the way through you've cut your meat
consumption down by two-thirds just with
these two meals here and uh and dinner
again soup salad steamed veggies uh you
want a healthy starch in there whether
it's
potatoes or a grain quinoa Millet
buckwheat or barley rice whatever
and you really want to emphasize legumes
in some form those are those high
protein foods that grow in a pod beans
peas chickpeas lentils find a way to get
some legumes into at least one meal a
day and uh whether that's a bean chili
or lentil stew or a hummus sandwich or
uh a bunch of alfalfa sprouts thrown on
your salad get some legumes in there as
often as you can and and eat all you
want to and I guess I'm always have
fresh vegetables at least once one salad
a day without a question like Dr Furman
says the salad is the main dish and you
gotta you need that fresh live produce
in there so we have a big salad every
day you can make a nice meal on just a
big salad open up a can of beans or
lentil and put them on top there with
your favorite dressing man that's a meal
so it's easier than you think and
finally the ethnic cultural issues here
find the one that you like the most and
find a way to make it plant-based if uh
if the person's phone loves East Indian
food well you can make some wonderful
vegetable curries without putting the
chicken in there you may use chickpeas
or other now legumes uh our friends from
South of the Border you can make great
Bean chilies instead of beef chilies
make these wonderful
minestrone soups uh there are certainly
ways to honor and enjoy the ethnic
flavors and they're available and still
stay Whole Food plant-based socially not
that hard just so look at what you
already eat and find a way to replace
the foods that aren't so healthy for you
and all of a sudden gee I'm doing it man
maybe five days they haven't any meat or
dairy look at that I need a lot of great
food right a couple of important factors
to add on top of that I think is really
helpful is eating enough calories
because a lot of people they go okay I'm
gonna take out the meat take out the
cheese but then all that but then they
don't replace it with the thing that you
were mentioning they don't replace it
with the hummus and replace it with the
healthy plant proteins and healthy fats
like avocado and then as a result their
meals are not filling enough and they're
not getting enough calories because
something I think a lot of people forget
is that plant whole plant foods are
filled with water and fiber that animal
food animal foods are not so you have to
you get to eat more bites of food to
become satisfied I like to say get to
because it really is with the ultra
processed food and animal Foods model
there's a lot of restriction involved to
maintain a healthy weight what would
plant a plant-based diet it's not that
like that at all and do you think that
was a very astute point and you were
absolutely right thank you for
correcting me or yeah I don't think it
wasn't correct yeah right but adding to
the point that yes absolutely you you
need the sufficient amount of protein
and soy protein can turn into tofu or
tempeh or edamame means those are
wonderful ways to get and get your uh
instead of um high protein features into
a meal as their meatballs so my wife
makes lovely tofu balls and mix them
with some tempeh as well and put some in
the spaghetti sauce so uh but absolutely
you need that those dense foods for
satisfaction and to keep your weight on
absolutely that's a valid point and then
the other thing you mentioned about the
veggie burger being a oh once a week if
that helps you transition thing that's
also a really helpful point because some
people might think oh it's vegan let me
just continue to you know it's vegan
whatever and then over time they think
I'm not feeling that great because
you're eating a lot of processed Ultra
processed foods in in the meantime you
know you can eat a vegan diet that has
cheat is filled with Cheetos and Oreos
that's definitely not going to be
healthy versus a Whole Foods plant-based
diet and I think when you say veggie
burger for people who are listening
that's that means like the packaged ones
with all the added ingredients the ultra
processed foods that we know versus a
homemade veggie patty which could be
made of lentils and different kinds of
sprouts and being different kinds of
beans and stuff and carrots shredded
carrots and celery spices that would be
a Whole Foods veggie value that you
could have all throughout the week so
that's really helpful I think for people
to see because it's very easy for people
to get in a habit of convenience Foods
when that's not really the way we were
designed to thrive excellent point
so anema Mundi herbals you guys if you
haven't tried anything from their
Apothecary shop yet what are you doing
I'm serious they are an incredible shop
with protein powders Herbal Remedies and
Beauty kits that are the perfect
addition to your Healthy daily habits I
am currently obsessed with our collagen
beauty kit and I'm gonna need to give
this kit to someone I love soon because
it really is enhancing my life it comes
with a dirty Rose chai collagen a super
fruit collagen an original collagen
booster powder and a collagen face oil
and rose quartz quas saw all made with
plants known for their collagen
protecting and boosting effects many of
the herbs within their formulations are
bone strengthening herbs that are
naturally high in silica calcium
phosphorus and other minerals this kit
is full of plant magic to help support
healthy hair skin nails and Bones enema
Mundy herbals was founded by herbalist
Adriana ayalas and her Apothecary uses
over 200 different sustainably grown
herbs from around the world to create
intentional products that contain zero
fillers binders or flow agents made in
the U.S with certified organic wild
crafted and sustainably harvested plants
and herbs in a vegan and gluten-free
kitchen they also use eco-friendly
packaging in recyclable glass or
biodegradable bags so I got a discount
code for you guys just enter the code
Ellen 20 for 20 off click the link in my
show notes below
and I really appreciated your point that
this is guilt-free eating I mean uh eat
to your full you know there don't worry
about calorie counting and Portion
Control I mean how many apples can you
how many how much kale can you eat you
know your belly's going to get full of
these lovely high fiber high water
content foods and so uh now once you
start adding processed foods and nut
Butters and oils and that changes things
but as long as you stay with Whole Foods
that like they're growing in the garden
eat all you want until you're until
you're satisfied yeah and in fact make
sure you eat until you're totally
satisfied and it also depends on maybe
your life situation and what stage of
life you're at because if you're maybe a
breastfeeding mom or like my husband
who's bodybuilding we eat even more than
maybe the average person so encouraging
like eating like I'm I'm eating as much
avocado as I want I'm eating as much you
know beans and potatoes as I want all
different coconut milk even all
different healthy high calorie plant
foods that keep me totally full because
if you're not getting enough calories
you're not gonna feel good and it's not
gonna help of you long term you are
correct so that's really helpful great
cool
cool topic of today about preventing our
number one America's biggest Killers
heart disease and even certain types of
cancers let's start with cancer okay
um what specifically which types of
cancers are ones that are diet related
and what are your thoughts on what types
of dietary patterns help prevent these
big Killers oh my uh very important big
and complex question here
um cancer is uh has many many facets as
our colleagues in oncology tell us and
um they're yes absolutely there is a
genetic component no doubt it we're
talking about uncontrolled growth of
particular cells in the body
and when you think of the
billions of cells that are dividing in
our in our systems right now did you
know our bone marrow uh is making new
red blood cells it puts every second it
puts in two million red blood cells into
the circulation every second that's how
fast our bone marrow is pumping out so
and so all the cell divisions happening
it's amazing we're all not sprouting out
leukemias and uh and Cancers from these
rapidly growing uh tissues are gut
lining uh it's a remarkable you don't
see more cancers than we uh than we do
plus that's combined we live in a sea of
carcinogens that our grandparents never
had to deal with but the water the air
everything we touch our Foods now have
pesticides herbicides and all sorts of
hydrocarbons from from Modern Life and
uh and those get into ourselves and they
tweak our genes and uh and can promote
the growth of cancers
um
there is a genetic component as I
mentioned if if a woman uh if her mother
two sisters and an aunt all died of
breast cancer at age 39 then clearly she
there's a genetic propensity in her uh
in her lineage there she needs to pay
attention to so so people can be
susceptible to cancers people say gee
I'm vegan I shouldn't have any disease
ever but again we are biologically
complex creatures we have lots of cell
division happening lots of chemicals are
impinging upon us that may cause
cancerous growth uh and so just being
vegan is not an ironclad guarantee that
you're not going to get cancer vegans do
get Cancers and and people if you become
vegan at age 42 well what were you what
do those 41 years ahead of you what were
you eating and what did what changes
that set off in your cells that may
manifest when you're 52 in a colon
cancer or something but hey I've been
vegan but yeah but you know it's the you
know the vegan people have been raised
as vegans since birth they're different
creatures I think they have a much lower
incidence way lower than people who
transition later on in life there so um
yes there's a genetic component and yes
there's lots of carcinogens around that
said
um there are clearly things that we do
in our diet in our lifestyle that are
more likely to to make it hospitable for
cancer to grow uh certainly if you were
inhaling cigarette smoke 20 times a day
a pack of cigarettes you are painting
your lungs with carcinogens from the
burning tobacco leaf and well that's
obviously I'm going to set you up for a
cancer of the lung we know that well it
turns out there's we eat three times a
day at least and uh and so there's a
steady stream of potential carcinogens
going down nobody eats raw meat the very
active grilling the burger or broiling
the steak or frying the chicken
oxidizes the cholesterol the muscle
fibers and the animal muscle turns them
into these nasty hydrocarbon uh uh
compounds that are carcinogenic they rub
on the colon wall and give a uh and
increase the risk of colon cancer
so local carcinogens in your diet so
meat as a big player is a big player in
that but then there's hormonal issues
food is so complex
we when when we eat food the body
responds
and when people eat meat full of protein
full of amino acids uh those the protein
goes down into the intestinal tract it's
disassembled pretty quickly uh there's
no fiber to prevent the enzymes from
getting in there dismantles it the amino
acids and the protein and suddenly this
flood of amino acids floods up into the
liver after a meat-based meal well the
liver suddenly gets all these building
blocks and it deliver things building
block let's build something with them
and his response to liver puts out a
surge of this hormone insulin-like
growth factor one igf among one of the
most powerful growth promoting hormones
in the body and it says grow grow and if
you if you're a woman with an early
breast cancer or a guy with an early
prostate cancer this is like pouring
gasoline out of fire so a high protein
diets can stimulate igf-1 production
and then in all our genes with the on
all in all our cells where our DNA is
all coiled up there is a set of genes on
their DNA
called mtor mtor and mtor genes are in
every cell and they sense the amount of
nutrients in the cells and when one is
fasting the amount of sugar and protein
and advanced plummet and mtor quiets
down uh doesn't uh well it doesn't
promote much cell growth but when the
opposite is true and is when in America
we're constantly eating when there's
lots of nutrients in the cells the lots
of sugars and proteins mtor is like the
factory form and there's an a where the
boilers are full uh eventually the coal
bins are full we got all the spare parts
start the Machinery start growing and
protein synthesis starts and cell
division starts and mtor is responsible
for all the cellular activity because
there's so many nutrients around
will you keep mtor activated week after
week month after month year after year
this is the recipe for aging prematurely
and as well as for cancer growth and and
sugars turn on mtor fats turn on mtor
and not the natural fats in the museum
and Olive or a walnut but the fats and
oils the Fatin in meat fats and dairy
food cheese all these fatty foods they
turn on mtor so if you're eating the
standard Western diet meat and dairy and
oil and sugars
um you're you're stoking the igf-1
production you're stoking the mtor
mechanism and and then Along Comes the
carcinogen that that trips up a gene on
a particular chromosome and that's it
all starts dividing and dividing and
dividing and the and the milieu that's
been created by the daily diet supports
that cell division and then suddenly but
well sorry Mr Jones but that pain you've
been having turns out to be cancer
throughout your abdomen how did this
happen well we've been kind of setting
the table for that unwelcome guests
going on with our daily diet and finally
to answer your question that brings us
around to the another body response and
those are the hormones that our body
produces some hormones some cancers are
really driven by high level of hormones
breast cancers are driven by estrogens
that women produce and with female cows
produce as well and
um and estrogens also make the prostate
gland unstable and so folks we eat a
high meat type supposedly High dairy
diet
the more Dairy more cheese a boy eats
the higher is risk of developing
prostate cancer when he's an adult man
so these hormone-driven cancers are
really susceptible to what we're eating
dairy is full of growth hormones it's
from baby calves and as I said the and
the sugars and the fats contribute to
obesity and and the fat tissue on our
bodies puts out inflammatory substances
and and other molecules that promote
cancer growth but Road inflammation and
cancer growth so a long answer to your
story but the sums that are most
successful to diet are the
hormone-driven ones breast cancer
prostate cancer but we'll talk about
General treatment of cancers in a minute
but again those earlier things about
creating that body chemistry where mtor
and igf-1 are raging uh that oh that
opens the door to all sorts of cancers
here
um and and finally to put a bow on it
you know there's such a difference
that's all and that's inherent in a
animal-based processed food diet that I
was mentioning uh and you you grill the
meat you create carcinogens well you
steam broccoli and you don't create
these carcinogens you boil rice you
don't create these carcinogens there's
such a difference between an
animal-based diet and a plant-based diet
the plant-based diet gives a message of
shh of healing to your tissues of
stability of antioxidant of lowering
oxidative stress it really changes the
body chemistry and makes it harder to to
promote a cancer growth here so yes food
makes a big difference when it comes to
cancers yeah I
learn I love all that you preface in the
beginning too about there's obviously
more than just diet that when it comes
to cancer it's really a holistic
approach to Wellness you know the sleep
that you're getting the stress the
healthy relationships in your life your
mind like there's so many factors when
it comes but like you said they're
specific ones that are diet related that
are so prevalent in America and I love
hearing the way that you explain to that
it's super interesting why is it do you
think that it's not more prevalent in
our society and media and just people in
general to talk about how diet can be
related to these cancers it's kind of
hushed it's just not mentioned at all
it's never it's not like you rarely
don't you rarely see it at all that it's
considerations of diet why do you think
that is
well you know there's that question
there's the 64 000 account in the room
or whatever mixed metaphors we're using
here and it's hard enough to get a
little cynical and I don't want to to
fall off into conspiracy land here but
we can be honest there's a lot of
interest making a lot of money to keep
Americans eating like they are and to
keep those Burgers going down people's
throats and to sell them all the fatty
meats and salamis and fast foods
um money money money is driving so much
at this and government subsidies make
these Foods artificially cheap so if
you're a mom with for a single mom with
four kids to feed it's it's cheaper to
go to McDonald's than it is to uh stock
up with produce and so there's many
Market forces uh if we were that are
conspiring against healthy eating if we
were if it was just pure science it
should be on billboards it should be on
TV commercials twice an hour
stop eating the meat Nigerian oils and
sugars in the processed foods eat more
fruits vegetables make some stews and
soups and salads and you eat whole plant
Foods you know there should be on the on
the TV commercials and everything would
change but a lot of people making a lot
of money from the status quo that's just
not serving us and and we're paying all
paying the consequences yeah and what a
big difference it is for people to
really see the difference between a
Whole Foods plant-based diet plant-based
diet all those examples you gave of
steaming broccoli boiling potatoes
boiling rice eating whole avocados you
know as opposed to hot dog buns just the
hot dog buns burger buns chips all those
things that are Ultra processed and
coated with all types of isolated
ingredients as opposed to Whole Foods I
think a lot of people don't want to eat
that way and they think oh you know this
is easier more convenient and maybe a
little bit more tasty because your
palette is used to it but when you get
used to the taste of Whole Foods not
only do you feel better but it starts to
taste better to you too and I think it's
it goes it's coincided because you
you're eating these foods and you feel
better so you gravitate towards it more
and then when you go back and you start
eating more processed foods or you're
eating take out more often or you just
find yourself eating more of those
convenience Foods you'll notice a
difference because you're so used to
eating Whole Foods and then your your
mind and your body's like get me back to
this because I feel so much better
eating this way and it's a holistic
approach really beautiful points
absolutely I totally agree with you yeah
and so do you feel like there is very
much data and science showing that these
are diet related cancers but they just
don't talk about it maybe in the
mainstream and so they're in the medical
journals but it's just not being talked
about very much uh short answer yes
that's exactly what's happening their
studies are certainly in the medical
journals it's hard to open up a journal
these days without some articles saying
plant-based diets are beneficial for and
good disease you know a lot of immune
disease clogged arteries high blood
pressure yes plant-based diets are
beneficial but uh the the science takes
a back seat to the to the dollar bills
yeah and you know that's the main
problem right now yeah and it's not as
sexy it's not as interesting to be like
you know broccoli is back no they're
going to do a Time article it says
butter is back everyone goes ooh I want
to see that telling me that I should eat
more butter I love that idea too bad
people love to hear good news about bad
habits yeah they do exactly so what
about the common topic point of sugar
feeding cancer let's get into that a
little bit
well the when you look in the standard
uh cancer literature websites Etc no
there's been that's a myth sugars do not
feed cancers but when you really read
into follow the whole article they
finish with all these ways you can
reduce the sugars in your diet is very
clear now that indeed when you eat
sugars or processed foods that turn into
sugar like white flow or like white
bread Etc
as the sugar level in your blood Rises
the body
responds by putting pancreas puts out
this powerful hormone called insulin and
Insulin drives sugar from the
bloodstream into the cells where it can
be burned and lowers the blood sugar
that's great but High insulin levels
also stimulate mtor and they stimulate
igf-1 production and so if you're eating
all day walking around with uh you know
a bag of Skittles or whatever and just
just if you're a grazer instead of
eating specific meals your insulin
levels staying up all the time you're
constantly putting sugar in your
bloodstream then you're walking around
with high igf-1 high M tour levels all
the time or mtor stimulating levels all
the time and um
this is a recipe for disaster and yes in
that way sugar certainly can stimulate
cancer growth and uh and I touched on
earlier there if the sugar contributes
to the person becoming obese obese you
know fat tissue on the abdomen and Under
the Skin produce cancer promoting
substances as well so in several ways
yes so we should not be eating sugar as
a food period you know that's the real
issue you know it's just talking about
fruits you know no I'm not talking about
fruits okay I'm a refined sugar turned
into an Oreo cookie turned into a
chocolate bar turned into ice cream
turned into cookies crackers whatever
that is eating sugar as a food it was
never meant to be eating as a food and
it floods our tissues with sugars that
stick to proteins and so off
inflammation the glycosylation reactions
are are not beneficial for the body and
so this is a distortion a perversion of
uh
the use of sugar it's a flavoring you
know they have a teaspoon of maple syrup
in your tea fine that's not wrong but
eating you know a donut or a vegan
cupcake then you know that's a chunk of
sugar that you're eating and it has
adverse effects No Doubt and how does
whole fruit go in in this topic that's
filled with antioxidants and water and
fiber and all the macronutrients how
does that do with this topic the answer
to half the question oh yeah there no
that's beautiful because when you when
you bite into an apple yes it's sweet
yeah you're getting some uh flavor from
the fructose and sucrose and other
sugars but what are you asking first of
all she says mostly water what you're
eating when you bite into any whole
fruit there and it's filled with fiber
that slows down the absorption doesn't
leap into your bloodstream sugar like it
does from a Cola drink and
um and it comes with vitamins and
minerals that help in the metabolism of
whatever sugars you are eating Along
Comes diamond and niacin Etc to digest
these sugars so all the way around a
fruit diet is beneficial every way you
look at as long as you brush your teeth
afterwards and to leave the food residue
in a longer gum line there there's
nothing wrong with eating fruits but
it's the refined sugars that cause album
and baked goods and canned desserts
really curious these studies that are
showing you that these cancer specific
cancers are diet related what types of
studies are they are they testing groups
of people and eating like a Whole Foods
plant-based diet versus
um eating a process Ultra processed diet
with lots of animal Foods or how are
they coming to that conclusion and are
there any specific studies you can
mention for people to look up
oh you put your finger on a very
important topic
nutrition science is a difficult one to
draw a conclusion from anyway
if you are testing a drug you can give
people a pill one has active drug one
has a placebo the patient doesn't know
and it's easy to do a double-blind study
on drugs but people know what they're
eating yeah you know if you're eating an
avocado sandwich or a hamster you know
the difference between the two and
people change what they eat over the
course of a week that it's not like
they're eating the same meal every day
it's hard to find people like that it's
hard to find people like that and so and
then they say I'm a vegetarian but I do
eat fish a few times a month when I go
out and and people are loose with the
definitions and when I look at the major
studies the Epic study from Europe to
seven-day evidence study now that look
at vegetarians again many of them
include dairy in their diet there they
are they have been vegetarian for very
long so so when I look at the The Meters
meat eaters evidence of disease X is
this and the omnivore that these are
soft numbers it's really hard to to make
solid conclusions from them
um so I don't put a lot of stock in
those studies but the in the general
indication when you pool all the studs
clearly the plant eaters have a lower
risk of all these degenerative diseases
and
um and when they look at specific
beneficial indicators or the antioxidant
levels in the in the tissues the uh the
amount of free radicals that are
produced in these various Foods Etc all
these are contributors to disease the
plant-based eaters come out way ahead on
all of those they need more antioxidants
they generate less free radicals from
preparation Etc so all the way around
it's a healthier diet but in the
long-term studies we they should do
proper studies they should follow 5 000
people have been raised as vegan since
birth and found them through their whole
lives
exactly right but that's what would be
required before people can say show me
the studies and let's see who dies of
what yeah do they die at all man so um
so the good research needs to be done
yet yes but that's why it's so helpful
to bring this up because a lot of times
people might bring up one particular
site oh look this one particular study
showed this but
a wide body of evidence say when you
pull them all together for one and then
the other aspect that you brought up
which is really fascinating is when they
study certain things like antioxidants
in the diet and then you can draw to
those conclusions of okay so people who
are eating more antioxidants in the diet
a helpful hypothesis is that this is
what it leads to and so it's really The
Wider body of evidence and the
importance of that instead of just
picking on one specific study we'll see
it yeah okay so what about somebody who
already has a diet related cancer and is
listening to this what advice do you
have for them right well again the same
general rules to create a body that
doesn't support a Cancer's origin
certainly applies when it comes if you
do have a cancer growing in your body
there the last thing you want every meal
to promote stabilization and to promote
order in cells and reduce oxidation and
stress hormones Etc so that said if
you've got a cancer friend the last
thing you want is a diet with medium
that jacks up your igf-1 levels the last
thing you want is a bunch of sugar in
your diet that turned that cranks up
your insulin levels and uh and that
activates mtor you know lots of fats and
animal proteins for the same reason you
don't want foods that make you walk
around with high levels of igf-1 and an
active mtor in your genes and uh and so
guess what that comes down to be yeah
whole food plant-based oatmeal for
breakfast and the soups and the salads
and steamed veggies in the minestrone
soups and all those things are exactly
what what one should be eating
um
often it's it's painful now with a
nutritional understanding to hear the
common advice given by oncologists and
family members because we all have an
image in our head not undeserved about a
patient with an advanced cancer and they
waste away the medical term is cachexia
they become cachetic and they they turn
into Skin and Bones and eventually
expire and that's such a frightening
thing for the patient to experience but
for the pain for the patient's families
to witness and for the doctor to witness
so whether you got to eat man keep those
calories going yeah it doesn't matter
what you have ice cream here they have
cheeseburgers whatever you want just
keep those calories in there but
ironically when all their good
intentions they're really stoking the
fires of of the cancer growth both the
very foods that make that cancer grow
faster and so the you want to do the
mirror image of that a big salad every
day don't do high temperature cooking
don't be eating fried foods and when
processed foods stay out of restaurants
as much as you can the whole plant Foods
on every level and it turns out there
are Foods we're now learning in the
plant kingdom that directly suppress
inventory activity in your cells and
guess what they turn out to be curcumin
in turmeric Resveratrol in grapes and
berries
genistein and soy products
methylindols that are in darking leafy
vegetables
what's in whole plant fruits have a
significant anti-cancer properties to
them and it's not a matter of taking a
handful of turmeric tablets and say I'm
cured and it doesn't work like that it's
this it's the stream the steady stream
of nutrients going through your tissues
meal after meal after meal that bathes
your tissues that bring that that
healing milieu to to your cells so stay
on the whole food plant-based side and
you're doing the best you can and stay
away from the oils as well
because it can be so easy to just go I
don't need to eat that salad today or
the steamed broccoli I'm just going to
go for this it's faster it's easier you
know just grab it and go type thing I'm
out and about I don't want to take the
time to make food but really whatever is
your priority will become what you're
able to make time for and eating Whole
Foods and that's abundance really is
what helps you with your longevity and
your aging and I think a lot of times
people can get
another distracted discouraged because
most people around them are eating
healthy right so but you've been doing
it for so long and how how do you feel
about that well you're certainly right
and the people around you are the huge
influence when we look at people who
adopted a vegan diet and then a few
years later it fell off the wagon and
went bad to their omnivore diet I said
what was the major thing what pulled you
off the way it says uh at the senior
home there my husband was antagonistic
we would go out to restaurants I was the
odd man out people kept asking me about
my my diet I was just socially so
awkward that it was easier just to eat
the fish at the restaurant it was in
once you open that door it's easier to
slide down the slippery slope there so
yeah but I do I do also feel like it's
helpful for people to know that it
doesn't have to be all or nothing like
for some people who are like I I really
like to go to this one restaurant and I
want to be able to go out and eat the
pad thai and eat the processed stuff
every once in a while I think the
importance is understanding is like
don't go do that every day don't go do
that you know even three times a week
like maybe once a week maybe once every
two weeks and then every other thing
that you have in your home keep it Whole
Foods and you'll start to feel the
results you feel so much better when
you're doing that doctor well said
advice yes exactly right yeah
well all right let's get into to heart
disease America's biggest killer which I
think is right above cancer if I'm
correct what steps can you take to
prevent high cholesterol high blood
pressure and heart disease
well surprise surprise that our gorilla
and our bonobo cousins and the trees
don't develop clogged arteries and
they're eating a high carbohydrate diet
full of whole plant Foods day after day
and their artery stay clean and and you
raise a child as a complete plant-based
vegan child who grows out to plant-based
adult there is no reason that child that
man or woman is going should develop
plaque in the inside of their arteries
if the only things are running through
those arteries are the digestion
products from rice and beans and greens
and fruits and veggies there's no reason
that those artery walls should become
inflamed and develop plaque there's no
reason they should give them the artery
walls get tight and get high blood
pressure for leading to strokes and
heart failure so these are diseases of
diet that if you don't plant the seeds
and nourish them they won't Sprout and
these are seeds you don't want sprouted
when we're talking about artery disease
and so
um uh the whole food plant-based diet
you know is the real key to preventing
this disease and as Dr ornish and Dr
russelston have demonstrated that if
even if you have plaque in the arteries
if you get on a really clean diet of
whole plant foods and soups and salads
and veggies and lots of lots of dark
leafy greens every few hours have a
little I am a portion of broccoli or
kale so those antioxidants are
constantly bathing the the artery walls
and they work through the antioxidants
worth the way into the plaques and
neutralize free radicals and help the
plaque start dissolving and breaking up
there it's not a punishment you got to
eat your greens four times a day you
want to eat those greens to keep those
antioxidants in your blood and you
maintain that state week after week
month after month
6 12 18 months later those plaques are
melting away and arteries open up the
angina goes away so it's reversible
disease and and that should be Beyond
Highway Billboards and TV commercials
and tick tock on how to keep your
arteries healthy you're as old as your
arteries they say and it's really true
only through a plant-based diet that's
been proven in research to stop heart
disease there's no other diet I've never
seen a paleo diet reversing heart
disease never seen the keto diet even a
vegan keto diet reversing heart disease
where before and after arteriograms to
show that plaque melting away but we
certainly see that with the whole food
plant-based dietary system made that
very clear
really common claim right now in the
ancestral eating world is that it's not
the animal Foods it's the seed oils and
the pufas and I think it's really
important to you know just hone in home
what you're saying you're saying Whole
Foods this isn't seed oils in the diet
really anyways but what are your
thoughts on maybe it's pufas in general
it could be nuts and seeds not and it's
not actually the animal Foods that's
causing heart disease and they'll use
this graph that say oh in the 1970s and
this is where we see the spike in seed
oils and this is where we see the spike
in heart disease what are your thoughts
on that
well there's seed oils near seed oils
and a matter of how they're used the
majority of seed oils
are cheap omega-6 heavy sunflower oil
safflower oil corn oil peanut oil these
are the cheap industrial oils that
that's what the french fries are are
fried and that's what the potato chips
are for fried in on the when you look on
the wrapper of the candy bar or whatever
and you'll see sunflower oil safflower
oil these are binding agents whatever
and you're right the more of that stuff
you eat those are not friendly to your
arteries for all sorts of the sugars
that are involved fats or oxidized these
are not healthy fats and and they're low
they're use in the American diet has
certainly increased in the last 20 30
years and yeah they probably played a
role in part of the artery assault that
as did the cooked burgers and the deep
fried fish and everything else that
we're eating and of that standard
American dietary style they they play a
role but to single them ah that was the
real cause ignore ignore all the uh uh
the the buffalo wings in the uh and the
fried chicken and the uh and the
pepperoni pizzas that we've been eating
it's the seed oils it's kind of a silly
argument yeah they play a role but it's
essentially it's you know as Dr Colin
Campbell may have wrote this very
powerful book called whole w-h-o-l-e I
love that book and he was singing it it
said don't start focusing on the seed
oils versus the egg yolks versus it's
the whole food stream moving through
your tissues at the what's in your
bloodstream after every meal that stays
there hour after hour and bathes your
tissue what's the whole effect of that
meal having that's where the damage get
done or that's where the healing happens
uh if you're just flooding soups and
sales and steamed veggies through your
bloodstream that's uh you bring a
healing array of molecules to your
bloodstream as opposed to the buffalo
wings and pepperoni pizzas there and so
for them to focus oh it's the seed oils
no it's still it's what's happened to
our Western diet it's full of meat and
dairy oil and sugar that book is one of
my favorite books the whole rethinking
the science of nutrition nutritional
biochemist D Colin Campbell love him I
would love to get him on the podcast I
know he's he's definitely is he 90 now
yeah he's at 89 an hour we just had a
birthday yeah amazing amazing real
inspiring right but those foods that you
did mention the pizza the buffalo wings
and french fries those all do have seed
oil components so they do so what about
specifically just like grass-fed meat
well grass-fed beef you know still it's
beef it's animal muscle and it's fully
cholesterol it's full of saturated fats
and you're gonna broil it you're gonna
you're gonna create carcinogens you're
going to set off a big bolt of igf-1
produced by your own liver it's meat uh
and
um it's it's damaging and gorillas don't
develop Cloud arteries they're not
eating cheeseburgers or even grass-fed
cheeseburgers uh it's kind of a silly
argument on now you know grass-fed beef
is any better well the feedlot beef are
eating grains that are sprayed with
pesticides and herbicides there's
probably less of that in the grill but
for the little bit less pesticides you
know it's still animal muscle carcinogen
saturated fat and it sets off igf-1 and
it's just we're not we're not
carnivorous creatures we're not the the
flesh eating ape that's not who we are
yeah that's like such an important
factor because people will say well it's
not actually the fact that it's me it's
because it's factory farm so it's the
source when really you still have the
same components of meat in the grass-fed
or the free-range chicken and all that
stuff of course yeah and something that
Simon Hill do you know who he is
nutritionist um he has a book called the
proof is in the plants I love him I love
how he explains the nutrition science
for to in response to these people
talking about the seed oils because he's
saying well in the studies you have to
say compared to what so if you're
comparing meat to maybe margarine seed
oils different things like that then
that you're going to get a different
result when you're doing meat compared
to Whole Foods legumes this type of
thing so you might you might want to say
oh it's just the seed oils it's just the
pufas or whatever but really there's so
many things that can contribute to heart
disease well said absolutely yeah so
let's see what's the next thing that we
need to talk about the percentage of the
of the American diet is comprised of
ultra processed foods and animal Foods
what do you know what the percentages is
that the average are for people oh it's
over 80 percent uh is either processed
foods or animal foods of some sort the
amount of fresh fruits and vegetables
like eight percent yeah it's like the
side component for people it's like a
little side of fruit or a little side of
broccoli lettuce on my burger yeah under
the bun there right instead of swapping
that out for the nutritious Whole Foods
the legumes and the tofu and the even
the tempeh and the rice and quinoa and
avocados and things like that tahini the
hemp seeds all that type of stuff so
um this is another important question
going back to the cancer same kind of
question I had for cancer why is there
so much conflicting public opinion on
animal products and meat causing heart
disease
well we've seen this now play out so
often a study will come out showing that
meat or sugar oil or whatever there is
you know it has this adverse effect and
you almost set your stopwatch
um before the first article appears from
the Dairy Producers or the meat
Association uh this uh this here's
what's wrong with this study why it's
invalid and it's a 16 points to refute
it uh because it's their livelihood they
uh they guard that you know first chakra
survival Instinct man lash that
Reptilian Brain lashes out and allows to
destroy any uh any opposition and uh it
goes billions of dollars are on the line
here and so um no you're not going to
get a
valid
uh feedback uh when folks who are making
their monies uh from the other types of
food are involved in the study someone
said Upton clear said it's difficult to
convince a man to see something when his
paycheck depends on him not seeing it
and that's largely what we're seeing
with the studies because you can always
find one or two outlier studies showing
that steak is good for you and smoking
cigarettes is good for you you can
always find a couple of these studies
but we look at the overwhelming evidence
of medical studies truly Whole Food
plant-based diets are what we should be
eating yeah and it's so important for
people to realize that there's no big
broccoli in the way that there is big
animal Agriculture and how much they
influence studies absolutely absolutely
and that's a lot in the book hole he
talks about the influence in nutrition
science that's such a fascinating part
of the book and he was on the board of
certain decisions for what studies would
make it into medical journals and how
much bias he saw stunning I mean that
should be talked about more that could
be an entire episode of itself he that
pays the paper plan calls the tune you
know yeah these guys are paying the
paper actually the tune comes out they
want to hear so it sounds like people
because I'm curious how much of it is do
people just not know or they just don't
care you know because like you said
people are being recepted to it you said
when Physicians are helping them and
reminding them look Whole Foods
plant-based diet are you eating more
plant Foods more Whole Foods that people
are being receptive or their patients
are being receptive to it and so I
wonder if a lot of it is it's just like
misinformation that is constantly being
put out in the media because of the bias
uh short answer yes uh both people don't
know and often people don't care uh
people don't know and as we just briefly
talked about
um it's in the in it's in the interest
of the meat industry the dairy industry
to when any studies come out to produce
as much confusion in the people's minds
as possible and and uh show a bunch of
opposing studies or this and that so you
uh it's a they take a page right out of
the book of The Tobacco folks uh who's
uh hired companies whose motto was uh
doubt is our product okay we want to put
doubt in the patient's mind without no
consumer's mind so they get to the point
well it doesn't matter they don't know
nobody knows what they're talking about
doesn't matter what I eat I might as
well eat this they don't know anything
and and the meat and dairy guys mission
accomplished yeah but that's just what
we wanted to create and so when they say
you they don't know because they're
being fed such misinformation of this
absolutely
and a lot of people say yeah I know I
mean my buffalo wings yeah I know a
chicken got a Ted chapter I don't it's
they're tough luck for the chicken I'm I
like my my buffalo wings here and a lot
of folks just don't care because they've
never seen a chicken they've never
touched an animal they've never uh meat
comes wrapped up in cellophane from the
supermarket and and we've so lost our
connection with nature uh we're
suffering from ndd nature deficit
disorder that we have no compassion for
these animals because they're never in
our lives anymore and the the meat
industry you know and you know each
individual I'm not you know I want to
say they're evil people they're all
caught in this in this financial
straitjacket where they got to keep
pronounce body they don't have anything
else to uh that they can make a living
from but the the ministry makes sure we
have no contact with the animals these
are the the hundreds of millions of
chickens and cows and pigs are in these
Anonymous aluminum sheds way up on the
hillsides there you see them when you're
driving through the country you have
what's up there you never even see them
but these are hundreds of millions of
living animals in these Dreadful sheds
here uh but they don't want you to see
that well they're just eat your buffalo
wing don't don't worry about what snow
shits and so the public when they say
they don't care because the agency had
no exposure to it and I'm really rooting
on the folks who bring the animals to
life uh who work in the Animal Welfare
movement because that's an important
link to important connection to make
something for people to really Ponder is
why it's illegal to film in
slaughterhouses why why is that in
factory farms why can't we show exactly
what's happening if it's really not bad
if it's not that bad if it's not
something we don't want to see it's
because we don't want to see it it would
totally put us off from eating that way
and even if it's a grass-fed free range
organic whatever versus a factory farmed
animal they all end up at the same
slaughterhouse and they die in the same
way and for anyone interested to check
out Dominion have you seen Dominion that
documentary it's a great documentary in
Australia actually a vegan activist who
snuck into factory farms and
slaughterhouses actually largely so
they're from any kind of you know life
lived from the animal until totally from
free-range grass-fed animals as well
because they end up in the same
slaughterhouse and they snuck in
recorded that footage and it is very
similar practices in Australia as it is
to the US so if you're at all curious of
like how bad is it would I actually want
to eat this way if I knew exactly what
happened watch that documentary it's
really good dominion and sometimes I
think what would it be like if you know
the supermarkets instead of having the
picture of the happy cow or the Happy
Chicken you know on the cartons if they
just had video footage above at the
supermarket showing okay this is how the
animal died this is how we got that milk
this is how we impregnated the cow how
many people would decide not to buy it
instead indeed Paul McCartney said in
the 90s if slaughterhouses he had Glass
Walls we'd all be vegetarians yes it was
absolutely right so so true it's really
really fascinating and it's easy to
romanticize it with certain terms like
grass-fed and stuff it makes you feel
better like oh the cow lived a happy
life but why if we wouldn't eat a dog
why would we eat a cow that is that is
the most the most obvious thing to me in
our biology going back to our biology
when you're talking about the chimps and
the bonamos indeed absolutely so one of
the last questions I want to ask you is
what other factors are related to health
then that we can round out this
conversation other than just the food
that we eat and since you work with
people and patients and helping them get
better are there any other lifestyle
factors that you help them to shift in
into their diet to help their Wellness
oh such a beautiful question to lead to
this point uh in the afternoon we're
Nash natural creatures we are we belong
here on the circum despite what we're
doing to the Earth and each other and
the other animals we we have a rightful
place to live if we do it gently and
reverently and responsibly and that life
includes moving we are animals we got to
move and so daily walk outside our daily
exercise in whatever form it works for
you is absolutely important uh we need
the basics like every other animal do we
need enough sleep uh we all get pretty
raggedy we don't get and there's no you
can't cheat on that your body it needs
in seven hours give it those seven hours
because it it ages you to cheat on your
sleep there we need fresh water the best
drink going in the world and uh and
low-grade dehydration is really a subtle
problem that's widespread and our tissue
reactions happen in the watery medium
and we need to give ourselves enough
water and so that's important
Sunshine whoever you belong out in the
sunshine vitamin D is made when that
Sunshine falls on our skin we'll become
so afraid of the sun these days but we
need to be on the sunshine at least 20
minutes half hour every day absolutely
and very importantly we are social
creatures we are tribal creatures we
need each other on so many levels and
emotionally and and economically and and
spiritually and so being well connected
in your group is important and a feeling
that you're productive that you're
helping things the same way by just
raising your kids or cleaning up the
park or teaching the kid to read or go
to go shopping for someone who can't do
the shop for themselves do something
every day to make this a better world to
to show more love basically we're here
to love we're here to learn and to love
and to laugh and uh and so if you've got
those things going there and a whole
food plant-based diet that's the fuel
that makes it all go that that brings it
up to fruition there you turn into a
healthy person at that point yeah so
Basics uh go a long way yep starts with
what you eat three times a day four
times maybe even sometimes I got another
t-shirt that says eat plants and get on
with it you know okay because it
ultimately it comes down to that um that
very issue you know is uh whether
talking about unclogging arteries or
avoiding cancer eat plants you know it
all still comes down to a whole food
plant-based diet love it well this is
perfect thank you so much for this
conversation I'm inspired I already eat
a Whole Foods plant-based diet but you
know I definitely dabble in my fun foods
and processed foods here and there and
this is definitely inspiring to like amp
up the broccoli amp up the berries keep
it up with my greens I ate so many
greens and just all that excellent yes
thank you so much you are so welcome
thank you so much excellent interviews
great job thank you okay bye everybody
another
[Music]